not guilty on all charges - former
Fullerton police officers have been
cleared in the death of mentally ill
homeless man Kelly Thomas tors rejected
second-degree murder and involuntary
manslaughter charges against Manuel
Ramos an involuntary manslaughter and
excessive force charges against Jason
Ellie the verdict
made it feel like he was murdered all
over again like it just happened today
the people are speaking out against
police brutality we were doing this in
honor of Kelly Thomas who is illegally
beaten by the cops to death in the most
brutal manner and we will not let people
forget I didn't expect this big of a
turnout I love all of you look at this
it's amazing this is shades of 2011 the
people are very angry this isn't over
there was no justice by these jurors who
just didn't get it and what they did was
making a statement that we the people
are not safe so if I'm bad cop wants to
do something to us they can
I'm not afraid of them right now I am up
everybody else say not guilty everyone
can see the beating it's online and the
fact that the jury saw that beating and
they said not guilty I have no words
they taught me that when a police
officer has me done it has beaten me in
the face of the Taser I'm gonna kill him
because Rick Baca says we all have the
right to defend ourselves and in the
words of the Fitz attorneys any force
reasonable I have to use deadly force to
protect myself or a police officer I'll
do it this isn't over by any means and
we're gonna support the feds any way we
can and the civil trials coming up where
we're going to actually get to see and
hear the termination letters from the
police department for each individual
they can't hide they will have to get on
the stand and testify in the civil trial
and the people are really going to be
pissed and judging from the size of this
crowd and the energy it's not going to
go away